what to you as a Critic of trump what do
you are
um the pros the strengths of uh Donald
Trump in which you are his biggest
weaknesses the strengths of trump
see how I can frame though in a way that
is both accurate and and accurately
assesses my my feeling about it and can
be taken out of context most masterfully
through the clipping process yes Trump's
strengths are mostly superficial and in
terms of presentation
Trump was able to I I call it a grift
some on the right say he's just so good
at relating to different types of people
Trump as a rich guy from New York City
was able to convince people that he
spent most of his life trying to be kept
isolated from that he had their best
interests in mind that he knew why they
weren't doing well in the 2016 economy
and that he had solutions that he was
going to bring forward the truth is
he never really liked those people and
as soon as they weren't useful to him
for a brief period of time he you know
that that love affair with his followers
stopped and then now it's back then he
needs them again
he didn't really understand the causes
of the problems that those folks were
experiencing and his Solutions were
laughable right like Jared was going to
solve the israeli-palestinian conflict
in year one he was going to replace
Obamacare in 2017. things that were
never going anywhere anywhere
um but what he did really well was he
put up a united front of I know what is
ailing you
I know how to fix it and I know how to
fix it I guess because he's a
businessman and he's been Above The Fray
of politics for so long knowing how to
use political donations to his Advantage
he called that smart Etc I think that's
his greatest strength why do you say
that the the the the the Jared plan for
israel-palestine and the plan for health
care to improve Obamacare why why do you
say this laughable well only someone I
would include the North Korea plan as
well which I'm glad to talk about only
someone who doesn't know anything about
the size and scope of these issues could
so arrogantly say that they could solve
them in that way and on that time frame
I'm all for optimism and and bringing a
new face to things absolutely without a
doubt but you know a wall with Mexico
that Mexico will pay for at the end of
my first term
I I know there are people who believed
it because they would call into my show
and say I'm voting for Trump because of
it but it's hard to believe that anybody
serious would fall for that unless you
were deliberately wanting to just
believe whatever was being fed to you or
you just hadn't ever thought about these
issues before the health care plan you
know in 2017 they proposed one would
have led to 24 million or so people
ending up without Health Care didn't go
anywhere because it was so terrible and
then in August of 2020 Trump said in in
two weeks I'm gonna finally have my
health care proposal it's 2023 we we
still never got it you know with all of
these things when you think them through
it was just sort of arrogance and I get
the perspective of I want optimism and I
liked that optimism it worked I mean
Fair a lot of people saw it and liked it
as someone who followed a lot of those
those issues closely
they seemed of course like impossible
promises well it's a double-edged sword
says it pushed back a little bit if you
look at the things I have
um a little bit more knowledge about
which is the space of artificial
intelligence
there's a company called deepmind and
it's a company called open AI
that were laughed at for a long time
when they were talking about that
they're going to solve intelligence
and now they've made especially Deep
Mind and I'll most recently open AI with
GPT they've made progress that most of
that Community would not have imagined
they'd be able to make everything from
alpha gold beating the wheelchair uh
world go Champion just all the different
steps and progress that can get into
were surprised everybody and they are
legitimately
uh fearlessly pursuing uh the task of
solving intelligence the other aspect he
gets a lot of criticism now but another
example is Elon Musk
uh in I can say a lot of things like
SpaceX so commercial space flight he was
laughed at for a long time that that's
possible uh same thing with autopilot in
Tesla autonomous vehicles his approach
was harshly criticized by all the
experts and I still criticized to this
day deeply criticized and I as a person
that I believe objectively can look at
the progress of autopilot as a
semi-autonomous vehicle system has been
incredibly surprising so the reason I
mention that is sometimes it feels like
you need the guy or the gal who's who
makes those uh Preposterous ambitious
statements like we're going to solve
Healthcare this year
like and then and then there's experts
like yourself that are looking thinking
have you read anything about the history
of the Israel Palestine is a good it's a
good example of that do you know there's
a history there do you realize how
complicated how many people have tried
how many people have failed how many
millions of people hate each other in
this in this little uh place in this in
this land that like sometimes the
expertise can really weigh you down so
it's sort of to push back sometimes you
have to have the almost be naive and
stupid and just rush in with an optimism
in order to actually make some progress
I agree with you 100 I think it's
interesting that all of the examples you
gave of of successes are from the
technology space not politics not from
politics which I mean listen I would
love to be able to make Headway on some
of these issues more quickly without a
doubt I do think at some point though
when it comes down to voting and saying
one of these people is going to be
ostensibly in charge for four years
through all of the Departments and
secretaries and choices that they make
we do want to apply some level of
realism with the with the understanding
that your examples are from the tech
space and they're good examples there's
there's no question about it one thing
I'll add to this I recently read Bradley
Hope's new book about North Korea
um and it's really about an activist
um who doesn't even really matter but
the in the background of the book
it's written much of what is written
about happens during the Trump era and
when Trump did the first and then the
second
um I guess you'd call them Summits with
Kim Jong-un and it actually did seem
like to some degree Trump's we're gonna
handle this like I do a business deal
approach to Kim Jong-un
in some sense it actually was logical
because of Kim Jong-un and the way that
it was so ego driven and they both as
sort of authoritarian strong men types
to different degrees wanted that there
was actually a kernel where I actually
thought as I read it Trump's initial
idea wasn't crazy the problem was he
knew nothing about the backstory of the
relationship he fell for all sorts of
lies from Kim Jong-un and he made offers
that didn't make any sense to me it fell
apart fine but that's an example where I
think Trump's personality was not
actually at its base the the problem
when it came to North Korea well there's
other things of this nature that could
go and some people argue goes into the
strengths and pros of Donald Trump for
China for example Terrace and China
can you make the case that there's some
positive outcomes of the way Donald
Trump
acted with China it's really tough and
I'll give you a couple okay then also
cons I'll give you it's tough to make so
the China thing is really so just um
very recently to when we're recording
this Trump was on Fox News interviewed
by a guy named Mark Levin and Trump
proposed a new I call it a conspiracy
theory maybe it will strike you with
something different about China covid
and tariffs and Trump's suggestion was
that the tariffs cost China so much
money China sent the U.S so much money
in tariffs
that they released covid as punishment
now there's a couple problems with that
one American companies pay the tariffs
Trump still doesn't seem to know this
Trump seems to believe that when he puts
a tariff on Chinese Imports
someone in China is cutting a check to
the United States
American companies buy the stuff from
China and then American companies cut a
check to the United States for the
Tariff
Trump doesn't seem to get that but it
still has a sting to the Chinese economy
you can make the argument that if there
is a suitable alternative domestically
or from a different country that it will
reduce Imports but but it didn't happen
and we actually have reports now that
the tariffs on China cost about a
quarter million American jobs
the other problem with that idea is
China created and released the virus in
order to hurt you
but as of today
5.7 of the 6.8 million deaths were in
other countries it's a very indirect way
you're mostly killing people in other
countries to hurt Trump maybe there was
a this is the sort of thing where when I
think about how Trump dealt with China
it's very scary because given another
four years who who knows what he might
do if he still doesn't understand how
tariffs work so geopolitics operates
in complicated ways with carrots and
sticks and Henry Kissinger has written
quite a lot about this and in some sense
the positive aspect here that uh Donald
Trump is willing to take big risks in uh
in the game of geopolitics with this uh
giant superpower that is China and a lot
of others are too afraid
too afraid to call them out to come to
the table and criticize
I certainly think that's an argument
that can be made my question would be
what tangible positive outcomes did it
lead to and it's tough to identify any
but I think it's a great thing I mean
listen
one of the things you're kind of getting
at maybe indirectly is that there's been
this sense that politics has been done
very similarly for a long time and even
between Democrats and Republicans
still even with some policy differences
there's still the kind of feeling that
it's disconnected folks in DC mostly
dealing with issues that don't directly
affect look I get that I'm with you on
that I think the question as to whether
Trump's Bluster
was positive rather than extraordinarily
humiliating in many ways I just come
down on it was an absolute and total
humiliation but I understand that you
can recognize Trump doesn't know a lot
of stuff but his attitude was refreshing
in some way that's a reasonable position
for someone to take I disagree with it
but I understand it but it's trying and
failing better than not trying
this goes well beyond politics you know
Wayne Gretzky is weighed in about this
Michael Jordan is waiting I mean this is
uh yeah is it better to have tried and
failed than never is it better to have
loved and lost than never to have loved
I don't know I mean listen we live
through four years of trump we know what
that four-year term was like
and it's very hard for me to say that
the things he tried
were were overwhelmingly reasonable but
I get the point you're trying to make
and I appreciate it and and it's if we
don't do any of it then where do we end
up sure we know where we ended up with
with Trump and it was pretty
embarrassing
uh okay let's linger uh on some more
strengths we didn't start any new Wars
we didn't search something to that yeah
that's it's it's interesting there's a
few different approaches uh to dealing
with that
um first it's really important to
remember that the Counterpoint to that
from the folks who like to say that was
that Hillary Clinton was going to start
three Wars sometimes they say four Wars
sometimes they say five Wars okay
um the geopolitical situation during the
four years that Trump was in office I
don't know that they obviously lent
themselves to Wars that Trump just
barely was able to keep us out of I
think the Russia thing is interesting
because now it's very popular to go back
and say you know the reason Putin didn't
do the Ukraine thing when Trump right
and to somehow give Trump credit for
that there's a Counterpoint to it which
is Putin under Trump particularly if
Trump got four more years would have
been able to maybe consolidate power in
other ways because of his relationship
with Trump I'm not coming down on one
side or the other it's not my area
expertise but it's not the open shut
slam dunk that you know Trump likes to
say it is Putin didn't invade because he
knew I would crush him and okay so it's
not obvious to me that there were
imminently Wars that would have started
during that time that being said
um you know for all the criticism of
Obama during Crimea
Trump seemed to just kind of forget
about that after all the criticism and
say I'm not actually going to do
anything about that and so there's there
are foreign policy uh criticisms that
that could be made but it is true no new
wars were started under Trump and I I
like that I don't like Wars what do you
think about us handling of kovid can you
say what are the pros and cons of his
handling of coven the con for him is
he'd be president right now if he had
handled it differently I think it's
abundantly clear
um early on and there's now a lot of
really good reporting about the
conversations he was having with Jared
Kushner and others
he became convinced either because of
things he was being told or because he
decided this is the way it's going to be
this is going to go away fine it's in
China okay it's in China in Italy okay
we have 15 cases but it'll soon be zero
will be open by Easter of 2020.
none of it happened
if he had handled it in the following
way and I've said this to Rogan and I've
said this to Patrick David and they tend
to all see my side of this if Trump had
said listen
we don't know how bad this is going to
be
but I care too much about the American
people to take a shot
so it's not going to be two weeks it's
going to be a little bit but I need your
help we're going to bring everybody
together I don't care if you're a
democrat or a republican we're going to
have Maga masks and he could have kept
50 cents on the dollar to pay off stormy
or whoever right but it would have been
I think he wins reelection because the
perception was and reality is a version
of that the perception was that he was
way too Cavalier about it early on uh
people died who didn't need to die
and
I think that it was arguably
the one area where he could have all but
guaranteed that he was going to get
himself reelected well to push back on
that I mean because you mentioned sort
of masks and lockdowns kind of a
solution to covid I didn't mention
lockdowns but I'm glad to talk about
Paul quarantino like there's several
solutions to a pandemic yeah broadly
speaking and one of them is a vaccine
and so you didn't mention that he'd Fast
Track the development he his
administration fast tracked the
development of the vaccine
which surprising he didn't really take
much credit for I think he did I think
he tried there's a couple there's a lot
there well to me it seems like
you could make the case
with the Trump hand gestures that his
decisions for fast tracking the
development of the vaccine saved tens of
millions of lives it could make you he
could in the trumpian way make that case
so couple different things I know you
don't necessarily follow Trump's rallies
as closely as I do and I'm jealous of
you for that but
um he did Tout The vaccine stuff hugely
for a while
until his audience turned against him
and then he had to draw this line where
he was going I made the vaccines which
none of you have to take by the way
Freedom you don't have to take them but
it's fantastic and nobody else could
have done it but don't worry nobody's
gonna make you take the vaccine and he
actually got booed at a couple of his
own rallies when talking about the
vaccines but let's back up a little bit
fast tracking my understanding of what
he did is he did what any president in
his situation would do and what many
world leaders elsewhere did as well
which is he agreed to a pre-purchase
supply of vaccine in order to provide
money to pharmaceutical companies to
scale up the manufacturing which is
absolutely fine but he wants one of the
stories he tells is it usually takes 12
years to develop a vaccine we did it in
my nine months thanks to me
Decades of mRNA technology being
developed created the platform in which
you can make a particular vaccine in
nine months it didn't have anything to
do with Trump
he did pre-fund and say we will buy huge
supply and that provided liquidity to
the pharmaceutical companies but he also
delegated control to uh to people to
experts that enable that kind of uh fast
tracking vaccines right he was very
eager for the FDA to approve it because
he saw that there would be a political
benefit he didn't get in the way I guess
he didn't get in the way fair I think
now we're on the same page he did not
get in the way of vaccines being
developed which is good presidents and
bureaucracies have a way of getting in
the way
and I don't uh disagree with that I'm
not aware of really any governments that
got in the way I mean it seemed given
the global situation everybody with
European countries were pre-purchasing
vaccine uh African countries were who
were going to be later to receive
vaccines were partnering with the
European countries that had
pre-purchased but the most interesting
thing about all of this is Trump did
play up the vaccines for a long time
until his his crowd didn't want to hear
about it anymore which was crazy it was
sort of like he became a victim of the
monster he created to some degree one of
the effects of all this that makes you
truly sad is uh this division over the
vaccines has created distrust in science
yeah and also what makes me sad is the
scientific
leaders Anthony fauci being one of the
representatives of that Community
I would say completely dropped the ball
in what way they they spoke with
arrogance they spoke down to people
they spoke in a way that's that a great
scientist does not speak which is they
spoke with certainty
uh with without humility uh like they
have all the wisdom and ever all of us
are too dumb to understand it but
they're going to be the parent that
tells us exactly what to do versus
speaking to the immensity of the problem
the Deep core of the problem being the
uncertainty we don't know what to do the
the terrifying thing about the pandemic
we don't know anything about it as it's
happening and so you have to make
decisions you have to take risks about
well maybe you have to overreact in
order to protect the populace but it's
in the face of uncertainty they have to
do that not uh not powered empowered by
science somehow and the Deep expertise
is something like Anthony fauci uh
claims to have so like the the I just
I'm really troubled by um yeah the
distrust and science that resulted from
that and that you have to blame the
leaders I mean to the degree
leaders take responsibility and I think
Anthony fauci was the scientific leader
behind
um the American response to the pandemic
and I think he failed
uh as a as a scientist as a
representative of science
I'm less um
I don't know if interested is the right
word but the kind of the the fauci
review is less interesting to me in
terms of what comes next than the first
part you mentioned which is the distrust
in science and sometimes I'll get
voicemails or emails from people in my
audience who say that I have had to
backpedal on certain things related to
this and one of the things I tried to do
from the beginning was not speak in
certain terms
when we really didn't have complete
information so there was this period
where hydroxychloroquine was first sort
of mentioned as a possible treatment
prophylactic or or you know proactive
treatment for covid or active treatment
for covid along with a bunch of other
stuff that was Ivermectin there was
vitamin D there were all sorts of
different things and I tried to be
careful to say right now we don't have
rigorous science that tells us that some
of these things work it doesn't mean
that won't come in the future at which
point if there was something as cheap as
hydroxychloroquine that treated covet
effectively unbelievable fantastic
it's not there's no way it ever will be
determined we don't have that
information right now so it's not Super
Wise right now to go and start taking
this stuff we eventually learned like
with vitamin D having an appropriate
vitamin D level does seem to be based on
what I most recently read generally
protective and a good thing when it
comes to infections of different great
okay so that one we we figured out one
of the really difficult things is that
the quote truth about the vaccines did
change and the original again this is
all I don't pretend to be an expert but
just someone who's synthesizing the
medical data and writing about it
originally the first vaccine
related to the wild type strain did seem
to be very effective not only at
preventing death and serious illness but
also transmission there were people then
saying it doesn't prevent transmission
over time as the variants came forward
the vaccine became less effective at
that at that point I started telling my
audience something different because as
far as I was concerned the reality on
the ground had changed in my mind that's
how science works it's not backpedaling
it's we're adjusting our beliefs to what
is taking place in the real world well
to be fair uh the scientists many of
whom are my friends virologists and
biologists they have way more humility
than people like Anthony faggio were
speaking about this or the CEO of Pfizer
who were speaking about this this is the
fundamental problem here is the way
science work is has the way science
works is there's usually a lot more
humility and a lot more transparency
about what we know what we don't know
and
um
people like Anthony fauci thought it
would be beneficial for the world if he
speaks with more certainty
but because of the political division
that formed around that that certainty
resulted in became completely
counterproductive that people didn't
trust anything about the vaccine didn't
trust any institutions there were that
contained the experts that actually knew
what they were doing and it basically
didn't trust anything that was coming
out of the models of scientists uh some
percent some large percent of the
population so you that made you
completely ineffective and uh
uh at scale as a society trying to
respond to a terrible pandemic and
that's where I put a lot of blame on
leaders so political leaders and
scientific leaders are the ones that
should Inspire us to all get together
and respond and that that should be the
case for uh the pandemic that should be
the case in the time of War all this
kind of stuff I I generally agree with
you and for me it's really about shared
blame and there were a lot of different
reasons why that the early communication
wasn't good uh part of it was I mean for
me I prefer accuracy rather than
overconfidence I would prefer listen we
don't really know right now whether
masks do X or Y what we do know is the
supply is really limited of this type of
mask we're going to try to keep them for
the front line workers I love that
that's the way I want to be communicated
to a call was made to do it differently
which was to say The Masks don't
actually help yeah but the real reason
is they want to keep them for healthcare
workers and then later The Masks are
what's going to solve I'm with I'm with
you 100 I think the other layer to it is
you can't ignore the political situation
at the time if Trump had won re-election
and the vaccine distribution had taken
place while Trump was President rather
than Biden my belief is that the same
number of Democrats would have gotten
vaccinated but way more Republicans
would have as well because they were
following not science but political
leaders and when it was Biden in DC
instead of trump a lot of those people
said I don't trust the vaccine but wait
it's Trump's vaccine I thought yeah but
something about the way Biden's
Distributing it so I do think you can't
ignore that political layer I agree with
you the communication was a disaster